good evening councillors
um welcome to the tonight's
performance governance and audit meeting
held on thursday the 29th of july 2021
my name is councillor jeanette stiltz
and i am the chair of this committee
before we commence business of this
meeting there are a few housekeeping
rules to run through
members the set up for the meeting has
been signed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
within the protocols
agreed at council on the 29th of april
2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hands
up or raise your paddle to indicate you
will wish
to speak then i will invite you at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask
put on your visor turn on your
microphone and speak clearly
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible and ensure your microphones
remain
off when not speaking
can i also call
the safe your um sorry
can i also call your attention to the
safety
of the building the fire exit is behind
me
and to please remember that the floors
here are on different levels when
walking around the chamber
berna do we have any apologies
for absence thank you chairman yes we've
received apologies for absence from
counsellors boyce and jarvis
thank you thank you item 3 on your
agenda
is the minutes of the meeting held on
the 10th of june
2021 it is recommended that the minutes
of the meeting
be held on the 21st
on the 10th of june 2021 and found on
pages
5 to 14 are approved as a true and
accurate record so i move do i have a
seconder
thank you councillor none
members do you wish to agree those
minutes by a cent
or move to a vote thank you
item four on the agenda is declarations
of interest
members it's to disclose the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
related to items of business on the
agenda have in regards to paragraph
6 to 8 inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose
any such interest as soon as they become
aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare please use the hand
or please put your hand up and use your
paddle and i will invite you to speak
so do i have any declarations of
interest
councillor fleming thank you chair um as
a member of
essex county council any item pertaining
and non-pecuniary thank you
thank you council for any any other
items
of or declarations of interest no thank
you
item five public participation i can
advise that we have not received
any submissions from members of the
public
item 6 on the agenda is
the report the internal auditor's report
progressor revolt affordable housing and
housing needs
audit knowledge management audit and
follow-up of recommendations found on
pages
15 to 56.
i call upon mr rubins
to present maripol thank you mr rubens
thank you very much um and it's good to
be back in person even though
perhaps not quite in normal
circumstances but i'm sure we'll get
there
um there's quite a few reports uh as
part of this
item there's four reports in total so
i'll take you through each of those
in turn and obviously there'll be time
for questions
at the end um so the first report is our
progress report
and i'm talking to page 18 here of your
pack
so you'll see we've got two reports that
i'll present
this evening on knowledge management and
housing needs
and then there's one further piece of
work from last year which is the fraud
risk assessment which will be presented
to the next meeting we've done the work
we've produced a report and we're just
agreeing that with officers
at the moment so that one will be at the
next meeting
and then there's a number of pieces of
work underway in the 21-22 plan
one other thing just to point out um is
you'll see that we've
moved one of the audits for this year uh
climate change and sustainability to the
22 22-23 year
and that's to give time to allow the
sustainability strategy and plan
to be developed and then obviously
that'll give us something toward it
in that year so if i now
talk to um the first of the two reports
that we're
presenting in terms of um audits that
we've completed
the affordable housing and housing needs
report and
that starts on page 23 of your pack
and i'll talk to sort of page 26 which
is the sort of key findings from that
piece of work so overall we've given
moderate assurance for the design of
controls and the effectiveness of
controls
and on the whole we've found good
processes in place for
putting together a strategy and
identifying your housing needs
um but the key issue uh and you'll see
we've we've raised this as a
high priority issue on on page 28
is that the council has not been meeting
its targets around
housing development um we
did think quite carefully about this one
is does that actually create a limited
uh opinion report but we've we've given
you i suppose the benefit of the doubt
and that actually if you look at the
numbers
uh the council is quite slow to start
with in in developing this housing but
it has increased
uh its pace um and if you take the last
two years together it's more or less
been on target but there's clearly still
work to be done around that um we've
also raised an issue about the housing
strategy board not meeting
and that's going to be put back together
so and also around commuted funds the
section 106 money is needing a strategy
for how you spend those so a number of
issues raised in that report and we've
had some
positive responses from officers to that
and clearly you know there has been an
impact of covid
uh on on the on the perhaps the speed of
which some of these things
have been done but there's work to be
done there
the third report in this batch of four
is the
knowledge management report which starts
on
page 37 of your pack and again i'll talk
to the key findings on page 40.
so again this is a moderate assurance
for design and effectiveness
we found on the whole the council's got
good processes
in terms of identifying efficiency
documenting those
getting staff involved and getting the
ownership of that and you know that's
been i think
on the whole a good process the key
issues that we've raised are around
um documenting the prioritization
process uh as to you know what what
areas you look at first
um and i think also on the business
continuity plan we found that was out of
date
so since the council has been
reorganized you need to update your
business continuity plan
in terms of the key offices in that plan
and obviously that's important
that people know who to turn to if there
is an issue there
and then the fourth of these reports uh
which is on
uh starts on page 49
is the follow-up of previous
recommendations um
and we've been able to sign off three
recommendations
with two overdue one of those relates to
building control
um which is a high priority but the
council has
uh recruited someone now to deal with
that issue
and we're expecting that one to be dealt
with by the end of september
and hopefully we can sign that one off
next time
um the other thing just to point out we
mention on page 52
is the safeguarding report you'll know
there were some issues there that
members were concerned about
we haven't followed that up yet because
the due dates for when those
recommendations are supposed to be
implemented hasn't been reached yet
but i understand from officers that
there has been progress on that
and obviously officers can update you if
you require
so that's quite a lot of to go through
but i'm very happy to take
questions before you take the questions
um can i move the recommendations
the recommendations found on page 15 of
the report are
little one internal audit report
um appendix 21 that the committee
comment considers comments and approves
little one
the audit internal audit process report
july 2021
appendix one little two the affordable
housing and housing needs audit
july 2021 appendix ii
the knowledge management and audit june
2021 appendix 3 and the follow-up of
recommendations
report march 21 at appendix 4. can i
have a second
for these recommendations thank you
councillor nunn
so i will now open the debate counsellor
none
yes sir thank you very much um chair and
thank you mr rubins for
your report um could i go to
appendix 2 please affordable housing
given the um criteria mr rubens for the
color coding
i found red to be quite harsh
in this report given that you've
acknowledged the difficulties through
covid
but unless i've misread page 28
this council over delivered
its affordable housing over two
successive years um
also um you've said that
you've had officer responses to some of
the queries
and i wonder really whether they have
been included in this report
thank you thank you mr rubens
so um well that's interesting that
perspective because
we've had other queries remember saying
perhaps we've been too lenient on the
council on this so i don't know maybe
that means we've got it right
but if you look at page 28 you're right
there are two years where the council
has exceeded its targets but not they're
not successive years so 2021 for example
68 delivery rate um so below the 100
um that you need so um an overall 49
delivery rate so i would say for you
know such a key target
you know i do think that that is a high
priority and it's important to see
that consistently met each year we do we
do have responses from officers so if
you look for example at the bottom of
page 29
there is a management response there and
it says that each of the
recommendations are going to be met
either in september or december of 21
and there will be member oversight of
that so as i said i think we've had a
reasonable management response to
those issues could i come back please
check you can
um so thank you for that mr rubens um
i'm not sure which members have said
that
um this is lenient uh because i thought
it was subject to this committee's
scrutiny but
thank you for your response to that i am
however very concerned
about the building control
element and how that's in red and that
that does
concern me greatly as far as development
in this within this uh
district council is concerned
yeah so my comment was relating to we
have a pre-meeting with members before
uh with the
you know the chair and the vice chair
before and i don't think they were
saying it was lincoln but they were
saying why did we
you know go down that that side of
moderate um
so um that that was that i agree with
you about the building control it's a
high priority
needs to be addressed but as i said
there is recruitment of someone to deal
with those issues and we are expecting
it to be
implemented next time thank you mr ruiz
thank you chair
thank you counts
oh mr leslie did you want to come back
before i go on to your
councillors yeah thank you just to
provide some more information about the
building control
obviously that line the reasons in terms
of resourcing it hasn't been delivered
to date
uh mr rubins has obviously confirmed
that there's uh additional
um resource in post temporarily now to
uh
specifically address that audit
requirement uh the latest update is the
work is nearly completed
and it is on track at the moment to be
done by the september deadline that's
currently been given
thank you councillor herder so you've
got your hand up and i see you've got
your hand up councillor hull councillor
heard
um thank you chairman um can i just take
you to page 20
please and uh
perhaps mr rubens can help me through
you chair
climate change and sustainability are
they two separate
audits no that would be one audit
okay the reason the reason i ask is that
uh obviously climate change is very much
in the current
uh in the news currently uh and i'm
wondering
why that one has been i appreciate you
touched upon it
so far but why that one in particular
has been moved to 22-23
whereas policy review perhaps maybe
didn't seem to me to be so urgent
yes i i think i did mention before that
the council is developing its climate
change strategy
and i think it's just one of those
practical pragmatic
um you know things that we decided it
would be better to wait until that
strategy's been developed and we can see
what direction the council is going in
what what actions it intends to take and
then audit that
rather than if we were to audit it
before that we'd probably be suggesting
things that the council would be doing
anyway it wouldn't
necessarily add value so that was that
was the conversation around that
but i do take the point it's an
important area
thank you and the second second question
if i may chair on page 26 again about
the affordable housing
target again we've
you've also alluded to the fact that
that we are on course to deliver less
than 50
of the affordable
housing target you've given a moderate
assurance on this although
allowing 130 affordable houses per year
over the last seven years from 2014 so
we should have
910 but we've actually got 400.
how are we how do you uh
get the assurance that we will be able
to be on target for that
yeah i mean i think that's possibly the
converse of the argument um
we were talking about before so i think
if you actually look at the last three
years so 1920 to what is
projected to happen in 21 22 you'll see
that over those three years the council
is expecting to deliver its targets if
you take those three years together so i
think
that's where we're seeing the
improvement um after what i agree is a
very slow start and that and that
is really what's contributed to the
council being so far behind
thank you chairman thank you mr leslie
you did put your hand up did you want to
come back
uh just ready uh to echo what mr riven
said around the climate
change strategy that is one of the
council's priorities uh strategy we're
coming forward
uh two members to approve so it felt a
bit premature at this stage but we
didn't have the approved uh strategy
to actually undertake an audit and have
been far more uh
effective to wait until next year
i'm going to go to councillor hall and
then i'll come to you councillor fleming
councillor hull thank you
and mr i it came to me this week that a
lot of the
um affordable housing have been sold to
a london council
is this so and if it is so do our um
local people do they are they still able
to
other housing still for them also can i
hand that over to mr swords please
good evening members no we often have
this rumor in the district i am not
aware of this current point in time of
any such situation of any
london borough buying affordable housing
out here
on all the strategic sites we're aware
of who the housing associations are
through obviously contact with them and
with the developers
and on those strategic sites um just to
reassure members that
as its new build people of the district
on the housing register in housing need
we get 100 nomination rights on first
lets of those properties
it isn't to say that a london borough
couldn't buy properties in this district
and do that as they have done in other
areas
but no i'm not aware of it and on our
strategic sites in any of the
developments i'm working with with the
housing associations
i'm not aware of any any london councils
buying buying affordable units
thank you mr sword councillor fleming
thank you chair um just turning to page
28
um the table table one uh it says
20 21 22 units completed and then in
brackets units expected
am i correct in thinking that units
expected is just
applicable to this year and how how do
we derive that figure is it just sort of
plucked from the sky
or or is there you know so far we've
we've achieved half and so it's
reasonable to assume that we'll
achieve the other half in the
second part of the year thank you before
i go into mr swords
uh councillor hull can you turn your mic
off please
and council fleming thank you mr sauce
do you want to answer that
um those figures that you're seeing over
you know
2021 and previous years um i monitor
on my own development spreadsheet with
all the developers and housing
associations
on a regular basis with them what's
happening with those units when are they
due to be complete so i'm constantly
keeping up to date with what's coming
through
and those numbers and figures i feed
into
the section 106 officer because i
believe he also does a half-yearly
report i think back to this committee
um on what's happening with all the
affordable in the district and the
figure there
we had to look at the financial year
so obviously we're still in the
financial year until
um april march april um and
obviously we've taken account there of
units so far i believed completed to
date
on that figure so we've still got stuff
coming through now
um up until christmas and into the new
year we've got affordable units coming
through
is there any more questions for this now
you've all had the recommendations in
front of you
um do you agree those recommendations
by ascent or would you like to go to the
vote
thank you we move on
to item seven which is the
internal audit and statement of
assurance
2020 to 2021 found on pages 57
to 76 i would call again on mr rubins
to present this report thank you mr
rubins
thank you it's worth me coming after all
um so this is
um our annual uh report annual opinions
it summarises our work for the year
so there shouldn't be too many surprises
in here i'm going to talk to pages 61
and 62
of your pack on this so um you'll see
overall we've given moderate assurance
that's our second highest level of
assurance
uh in terms of um you know where we
think you are overall
on governance risk and control and it's
the same level we gave last year
i think on the whole actually if you
look at the individual opinions
there's been an improvement since last
year we've got no limited opinions this
year
and that's good to see and i think
particularly given the circumstances of
the year with covid
uh and the pressures on on staff i think
that's a very positive
um uh conclusion there's still are some
issues obviously and you know we've
talked about the housing
uh report there was the safeguarding
report as well that we presented earlier
in the year
so still some things to address i would
say and you'll see on
on the themes on page 69 we've tried to
sort of summarize some of the areas
uh that we think the council perhaps
could look at that in terms of
you know we think that there's some
generally good processes uh
well-designed processes but the
implementation sometimes
is not a hundred percent consistent so
there's still work to be done around
that
but i think overall as i said i think
it's a positive report
and we also comment on the back of the
report on page
73 on the internal audit performance and
again i think
um that's gone pretty well in terms of
delivering the plan
um you know still challenges for us as
well in terms of delivering under covid
uh and you know we'll we'll we'll be
aiming to for more timeliness
next year in terms of completing the
plan earlier in the year but i think
overall
we've had good feedback on our work and
hopefully that will be endorsed by
members but happy to take any comments
or questions
thank you before we go to that i would
like to move the recommendations
that the committee considers comments
and approves the
little one internal audit annual report
and annual statement of assurance for
2020 21
at appendix one can i have a seconder
thank you councillor none now i out in
the debate
does any members have questions
councillor heard
um thank you i just want to be clear on
page 62
it says in the um year the majority of
audits provide substantial assurance
and it says limited is one and then in
the second
point it says unit is two
and then the third one says we did not
issue any limited insurance reports this
year
i'll just be unsure which year you're
referring to is it the current year the
previous year
or this year so we're referring to the
year 2021 so the year ending 31st of
march 2021 and in that year
there were no limited opinions but we
then give in brackets the figures from
1920s so the previous
year to that where there were some
limited opinions and that's where those
numbers come from
i hope that's clear
any other questions
no
you've had the recommendations in front
of you members
would you like to um agree these by
ascent
or move to a vote thank you
mr rubens thank you very much for that
item 8 on the agenda is the external
audit and audit planning report
to march 31. you move to item
8 on the agenda found on pages 37-50
no it's not random ages 77-108
mr wisdom would you like to come and
present your report
so
thank you mr wisdom
hey good evening good evening everyone
um
as per usual i'll assume the document is
red but i will just pull out some of the
key messages
um so just a reminder that the the work
that i perform
continues to be carried out in
accordance with the code of order
practice and supporting regulations
which are published by the national
order office
the the scope of my work includes the
audit of the accounts
along with satisfying myself that the
council has made
proper arrangements for securing value
for money
there have been significant changes to
the code with respect to the value for
money requirements and these are set out
in more detail
on page 94 of the pack the materiality
level that i use
has been set on a consistent basis to
that that i used in previous years
and that then calculates at 1.2 million
pounds
it is worth mentioning it is worth
remembering though that i do report all
errors that i identify through the
course of my old in excess of sixty
thousand
pounds whilst my overall materiality is
high i do report to all areas over sixty
thousand pounds
um as you would expect the pandemic has
continued to impact the order both in
terms of the risk profile
as well as the way that we conduct the
audit and again there is more detail on
that on pages 88 and 89 of the pack
the significant risks that i'm going to
be focusing on this year are
management override of controls
a reminder that auditing standards
presume that there is a risk
around accounts being fraudulently
mistaken by
management around overriding of controls
so this is a significant risk for every
single audit that we have it's not
not unique to to moulding
the areas that we focus in for this risk
are the preparation of accounting
estimates
looking at inappropriate journal entries
and and also transactions which have no
economic substance
the second significant risk is is a new
one this year
and it is the recognition of covert 19
related income
the reason i've included this is a
significant risk is because
as i'm sure you're well aware there are
a number of new grants with a
significant value
which are accounted for and these grants
can be accounted for in different ways
and some of them require judgment as
well as to how they're accounted for
so those are the two significant risks
but i also have
some areas of focus that i've
highlighted in
in the plan those areas are focused on
the pension liability
again i focused on this last year and in
particular i'm looking at the
assumptions that are used
as part of that calculation of that
actuarial liability
and the second area of focus again is
will be familiar to those of you who'd
be on the committee
and we'll be focusing on the valuation
of property plant and equipment
you may well recall that this was
escalated to a significant risk
last year due to the limit of errors
that were identified
however having reviewed the results of
our work and also the council's response
to our recommendations
i've downgraded that back down to an
area of focus
for for the year there's more detail
on each of the significance and areas of
focus within the within the report
i chair that's the uh the highlights
from the report that i was in my plan
that i was going to put out but i'm
obviously happy to take questions
thank you before we take those questions
i will move the recommendations
and the recommendation asceta in the
report is as follows recommendation one
that the external audit planning report
as shown in appendix one be considered
can i have a seconder for that
recommendation thank you councillor nunn
uh members i open the debate counsellor
nun
uh thank you chair and um thank you mr
uh
wisdom and i'm surprised that you're
gonna focus on
pension liability um as an issue bearing
in mind that
this is a local authority and the staff
if they're in a pension scheme will be
in
local government pension schemes so it's
a
a nationally recognised scheme and any
liabilities i would have thought would
have been
assessed by the actuary so what exactly
will you be auditing when it comes to
that
please uh certainly so
so you what you say is entirely correct
but
the the outcome of everything that
you've said is that there is a
significant liability
that sits on the council's balance sheet
and that that liability is is large but
it
it's also very judgmental so those
actuarial assumptions
um they are determined by an actually
absolutely but they are
subject to a lot of judgment so that's
one element of of it but the
the other area that there is judgement
around is there are
there are a number of assets that
obviously reduce the overall
actuary or with the liability that
appears on your balance sheet
and again some of those assets are off
relatively straightforward
so they are valued gilts for example are
very
relatively straightforward but other of
those assets are actually quite
difficult to value and again there is
significant judgment
associated with those assets so for
example if they were invested in private
equity funds
so the combination of those two elements
there is a lot of judgment there is a
lot of estimate and
the the the result of all of that is a a
large liability that sits in the
council's
balance sheet and that's why i have it
as an area of focus
could i come back on that please check
thanks thank you for that and wisdom
but the presumably that when you talk
about the investment
the investment is by the scheme not by
this council
yes you're correct uh but the the scheme
uh as i say ultimately the liability
does sit on the
on the council's balance sheet and this
and the council is responsible
for that liability so yes the the
investment
decisions are made by the
by the uh the pension scheme and
there is a pool of assets but the
results of those decisions
directly impact the council because the
the end result
is the the net liability that sits on
your balance sheet so
yeah so sorry just in conclusion then so
so you're assessing the risk
but it's not a controllable risk
it's i would agree with you it's not
directly controllable by yourself
no but but it is still that it does
ultimately fall to you as a counselor is
ultimately your responsibility to ensure
that the number is correct because it is
in your accounts and you're signing off
that those accounts are correct
okay thank you mr wizard thank you chair
thank you mr
leslie wants to come in on that
probably just to make clear as well that
uh quite rightly the
pension fund is administrated by essex
county council
they look after that for the district
authorities and they will be using their
actors
to get the figures which they will then
provide to us
and they have those figures audited um
as well
so it's those figures from essex county
accounts as actuaries
which we use and we don't want to see
administrator the schema
okay councillor stevens
thank you chair my questions about the
fees that are outlined on page 106
um seems to have gone up from 54.8 to
88.6
000 in a year it does say something
about a scale fee
increase but as a new councillor i'm not
too sure what that means could you
explain that for us please
thank you
um yes so um in terms of the
the fees that we've put in there again
as
a new council we've had we've had a
number of discussions around
um fees and the the the fee that's in
there is the proposed fee from me which
still has to be approved by
psaa so the the scale fee is the
is the base fee that is set by psaa and
anything that is above that scale fee
then has to be
approved um by pso well it has to be
approved by the council and psaa so
again i'm
i'm happy to to provide further detail
if
needed in terms of the historical um
position but as i said that
there was a paper that has come to
previous committees which set out the
basis for that fee which
um that the council has then asked for
uh psa's input on
and psa are in the process of assessing
that and then we'll come back with the
decision on that as well
i'll go to mr leslie so you might be
able to clarify some
thank you so yes we've held a number of
discussions um
around this and we have circulated a
briefing paper to the committee
um but i'm not sure whether you were on
the committee at that time
because as soon as i'm happy to
circulate i think they'll be beneficial
to perhaps do that round to the
new committee um which perhaps would
answer some of the questions but yes
we've been engaged
uh with the exterminators for quite a
while around those fees
the scale fees were set several years
ago
now and they uh subject to fee
variations
and i think mr wisdom has explained that
due to the nature
and the increases in auditor
requirements which have been substantial
over recent times um we've seen a lot of
increase
in terms of audit fees around that
side of it the fee has been reduced
through initial discussions
and what will happen now with the fee as
once the audience concluded
the authors will submit that to the the
body the psaa
who will review those fees on behalf and
they
effectively give the judgment around
that if they're if they feel they're
fair and they have the final say
they will contact us as well within that
process so we can put our side across
and part of the work they do as a large
body look after uh
i think all of the councils um audits as
well they
will do benchmarking and from time to
time they could even look at
uh some of the work that the authors
haven't taken and have a look at that
to do that so that's where their skills
expertise and benchmarking ability
come in but until the audit is completed
that process can't
take place counselor heard
why
so so um mrs wright when he describes
the fact that the audit
of essex county council happens but
essex county council represents a number
of
different bodies that you know the staff
that are employed by a number of
different councils is not just malden
what they what the actuary does is they
they work out on molden's specific bit
of the essex that the toca pot is
and then they send those figures across
to malden
so the numbers that are audited by essex
expansion scheme
on the whole of the pension scheme so
obviously those incorporate more than
but they they
will order to a much larger and a much
greater materiality because they're
looking at the whole thing
whereas what i'm interested in is the
bit that's been carved out and is that
bit that's been carved out
is that correct um and there's the
liability that's ultimately
resting that is the liability that
management are recording or council
officers are recording in the back in
the accounts is that the right
amount for moulder and so that's the bit
that i'm auditing
is there any other questions counselling
um
fleming thank you jen
i just wanted to go to page 103 appendix
2
uncorrected missed statements i just
wanted
an explanation for both
items there overstatement of council
office valuation and the goodwin
judgment
impact pensions thank you
mr leslie thank you thank you
yes those were the ones from last year's
accounts
the valuation of the office's valuations
by their nature are subjective
and it's below materiality so there's no
requirement to change
um those uh from perspective i could
just check
is the question why weren't they just
adjusted for or why did
yeah just interested to to know how they
occurred
thank you okay so in terms of the
evaluation of the office
um it relates to i believe the overflow
car park there so essentially it was
a bit of a double count in the
valuations and it included
the car park twice i think that was the
main issue
around that and in terms of the mcleod
judgment that again relates to the
pension
scheme so late in the day we had an
adjustment
to the original pension uh value but
because obviously the size of the scheme
and the fact that delightfully an
estimate
we didn't adjust for that when we had
subsequent information
from the actuaries around the impact of
the mcleod judgment to the pension fund
liability
is there any other questions for mr
wisdom or mr leslie no you have the
recommendations before you
our members happy to accept those by
ascent or move to a vote
thank you thank you mr wisdom for
that presentation item 10 on the agenda
is any other business that the chairman
decides is
uh urgent i have none so item 11
on the uh agenda is closure of the
minutes thank you members thank you for
your contributions this evening
i draw the meeting to a close at ten
past
eight uh as member as the meeting is now
closed members are advised not to enter
into any further discussion on this
you